the 2024 race for the White House is
heating up just yesterday the Trump
campaign announced a staggering second
quarter fundraising Hall
and amid Biden's struggles Trump's 2016
opponent yes her Hillary Clinton is
Raising speculation yet again she's
headlining a list of speakers at the
NAACP National Convention
but according to a new gallup's survey
Independents are quickly on the rise
with 44 percent of Americans no longer
identifying with either major political
party
so does this open the door for a
possible Third Party candidate according
to many reports the so-called No Labels
group a growing Centrist movement is
eyeing a third party run
and with West Virginia Democratic
senator Joe manchin at the top of their
list
Democrats are raising alarm
here with reaction pulster Lee Carter
former Florida attorney general Pam
Bondi and former State Department
spokesperson Morgan Ortegas what a great
panel this is Pam let's start with you
he worked with the administration you
were the first woman elected to your
position as attorney general in Florida
history you know a lot about campaigns
you know a lot about politics but you
know an awful lot about governance I
mean how do you see this playing out for
Joe Biden and Clay Travis saying he
doesn't even think Biden will be the
nominee
well I think he has big problems as he
said and you know we have Governor
Whitmer out there making appearances
Gavin Newsom of course on Sean Hannity
and Hillary Clinton at the NAACP I mean
the hypocrisy of that is beyond me
because look at the 1994 crime bill
um kellyanne remember that that her
family passed which by all the black
community accounts was disappointed
proportionately impacting the black
community by the mouse incarcerations
versus what Donald Trump did for our
black community giving black colleges
permanent Federal funding which was
unprecedented and the lowest the
absolute lowest unemployment rates so
you're looking at that and these
candidates versus Donald Trump assuming
he is our nominee I firmly believe he
will be on the Republican side and it's
also very very difficult to get a third
party candidate on the ballot so if they
try to run a No Label and no Third Party
candidate it's going to be very
difficult as you know it's going to
require hundreds of thousands of
signatures to get someone on the on the
ballot but yeah I think they're
frustrated with Joe Biden especially
based on the video that you showed at
the beginning of your segment
yeah the new Echelon in size poll shows
that the third party candidates really
do tend to hurt Joe Biden Lee Carter you
and I are posters of that's a female
pollster posters and I know you study
this a day in and day out for many
decades there's no question where people
call themselves Independents they refuse
to pledge allegiance to either party
they're declaring their independence
from both political parties but in
Practical terms who really has the
advantage right now on the issues as
goes the independence
well you know people don't like labels
but they really do identify one way or
the other so most people there's really
only about one or two percent people who
are truly independent and what we're
seeing right now is most people are
leaning more Republican but there's some
issues that they have issue with but the
issues that are most important to
Americans revolve around the economy
where um where Republicans do much much
better with Independence it also is on
immigration crime
um corruption all of those issues favor
Republicans and that's where a lot of
Independents are are putting online the
one issue where it does not favor
Republicans is abortion and that falls
way way down on the priority list but
might be a driver of some people's vote
and Morgan as our resident foreign
policy National Security expert here a
former spokesperson at the state
department there's no question that
people are concerned about international
issues and National Security and and the
disgrace and dishonor that Joe Biden and
Kamala Harris has brought to our nation
around the globe how do you think that's
going to play with Independence and in
the 2024 election
well we can just look kellyanne at the
news cycle in the past few months and
what do we see happen first it started
with the authorities uncovering these
chinese-run police stations these secret
police stations in the United States
then we famously saw the Chinese spy
balloon that traversed the United States
and was allowed to collect everything
that it needed to collect before finally
being shot down now we have news and the
administration hasn't been able to get
their story right but we have news of a
a Cuban a spy Base in Cuba that is
funded and paid for by the Chinese so
we're talking about you know close to
American Shores having a spy facility
that is funded and equipped and paid for
by the Chinese Communist party and I
think Americans why they may not pay
attention every day to foreign policy
the way I do I think they understand
whenever they see a weakness on the
world stage and kellyanne you and I know
we handed that Abraham Accords which
were peace deals the first piece deals
between Israel and Arab states and 26
six years we handed those to the Biden
administration of what happened within
you know just three months Hamas was
attacking Israel within seven months
under Biden's leadership the Taliban had
taken over Kabul and within a year you
have the worst year war on European soil
since World War II when Russia invaded
Ukraine there is a lack a key lack of
deterrence in every theater in this
planet coming from Biden all the way
down to his secretary of state and the
rest of his National Security leadership
so well said it's very important to
remember all that Morgan thank you so in
our remaining time I'm going to point
out that in 2024 many Americans are
saying that they may look for a third
party they may not but I think both
Front Runners Trump and Biden kind of
are ignoring the traditional campaigning
and you see other people out there
flipping burgers and making pancakes on
July 4th I'm going to give each of you
very smart women a moment to a time to
give advice to either Biden or Trump Pam
we'll start with you
well I think Donald Trump is doing
exactly what he should do we saw him on
the CNN town hall and I think his polls
went up even higher if that's possible
after that I think Joe Biden needs to
give interviews and he's not going to do
it for all the reasons that you showed
us and if not if I was a Democrat I
would want him to walk away and let
another Democrat run for president
because he cannot do it leave your
advice to either of them or anyone else
in the field for that matter
well I think on the Republican side that
the issue has to be made about the
economy and making our lives better
um the Republicans continue to make the
case on how bad it is Americans know
that seven in ten Americans say we're
going in the wrong direction depending
on the public some say it's worse
Republicans
have an answer have Solutions and so I
would say to all the Republicans that
are running DeSantis focus on that don't
focus on the culture wars as much focus
on how you're going to make the lives of
everyday Americans better because you do
have you have the edge there no doubt
about it Morgan you get the last word
uh listen I'll give advice to President
Biden I think you should go home and
play with his grandchildren also how
many of them also perfect well done Lee
Pam and Morgan thank you very much I
know everybody's listening hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else